كيف الناس يبحث عن يعني الاثاره ما يبحث
على العلاج لسيادته او تصليح سيارته
كيف كفيف يصلح في السياره انا بنجربه
بنجيب لها سيارتي وبتجربه عندما يجي ويجيب
سيارته ويجربني
يلقى
التصليح كويس والتشخيص كويس وكل شيء
يتفاجا
[موسيقى]
الاسم عبد الرحمن عبد السميره سكان
المدينه
وراثي وهو عشان ليلى هذا مرض شائع يعني في
العالم كله احاليا الطب يبحث عن الحلول
للمرض هذا في البدايه اول مفقات البصر
الحج صارت لي نكسه نكسه وقويه شويه والحمد
لله بارك الله في الناس اللي وقفت معي
واهلي يخلوني نطلع من نفس هذه خلال سبع
شهور فقط
يعني بدايه الشباب كنت همم مبصر تعلمت
يعني الميكانيكا لكن مش بشكل كبير يعني
همم عباره عن
مفتاح همم ضد قطعه هذه يركب القطعه هذه
لكن ما غير اي خبره ولا اي همم فهم
للموضوع لكن بعد ما فقدت البصر عنده 24
عام تقريبا القصه هذه
مش
نحب الميكانيكا ونحب نتعامل مع
التصليح او السيارات
المتميزين وخلطناهم وعلى المونه
[موسيقى]
نعتبر روحي تعلمتها بسرعه خلال سبع سنوات
او ست سنوات تعلمت الميكانيكا والحمد لله
اخوي فقط بصل حتى هو وفي الفتره الاخيره
بعد ما تجوزت الحق اللي كانت الوقفه
الجاده والحقيقيه من زوجتي والحمد لله
كنت وحدي في بدايه الموضوع كنت نخدم روحي
وعندي زباين وكل شيء بعدين اشتغل معايا
ابن اختي هذا طلعت معي فكره الورشه
المتنقله قصه الورشه المتنقل هذه كنا همم
بدايه كل كان مجرد فكره لكن فكره هذه كبرت
دماغ
وحاولت اني دير لها تفصيل في راسي مفكرتي
طبعا همم
لكن مبسطه شويه
كانت الفكره بسيطه كانت اني بتدير سياره
متنقله من دفاع عندك وكل شيء بعدين ربك
اطعمني واعطاني من خيره ان جتني سياره
هديه اللي هيا
السياره اللي قاعد فيها حاليا
تشخيص الحاله او تشخيص العطل بتاع السياره
هو اللي يقنع الزبون شخص صحيح وتقول لك
كيفيه العلاج او التصليح يقتنع بالشارع
وفي من الناس قالوا لنا الشرف انه يصلح
حالنا واحد كفيف وفي بعض المبصرين ما
بقدرش يوصلون النتيجه
نستعمل في ثلاث حواس لحقه مصر اني
استعملهم اللي هي حساسيه الشم او السمع او
المس هذه ثلاث حاجات يعني ضروريه بالنسبه
لصنعتيني السابع في حاله ان في صوت غريب
في السياره
تحدد به نوع الخلل او ما كان الخلل
طبعا الزيوت والشحوم همم الوقود للسياره
يتغير مع الاحتراق ويتغير مع همم بالنسبه
للوقود تخش همم بنفس الرائحه وتطلع بنفس
الراحه بتكون فيها يعني
بالنسبه لي المحرك لكن اعطال ال- همم
الصاله او ال- همم
الكمبيو تحتاج قياده يقول لي صاحب السياره
يسوقها معي المعاونه
حتى نحدد كان في عطل ثاني او شيء مشكله
ثانيه
الورشه الحمد لله وكانت موجوده توا حاليا
بعد ما علمنا باها مشوار
وسعينا في المجال هذا مشوار وربك قدرنا ان
درناها الورثه باذن الله في خطوات ثانيه
فيهن افكار جديده و باذن الله هتتنفذ
[موسيقى]